il compte dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique il est conscient
qu'il ne suffit plus d'alertés de nous
dire que la maison brûle il faut passer
à l'action il a imaginé un monde
décarboné avec de nouveaux modes de vie
une économie florissante et le plein
emploi voici jean marc jancovici
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue enfin vous en prie
bonsoir jean marc jancovici bienvenue
sur le plateau decotidien vous êtes
ingénieur youtuber enseignants et
fondateur du shift project c'est ce
qu'on appelle un think tank c'est à dire
un groupe de réflexion sur l'écologie et
vous publier ce livre cash et concret
qui s'appelle le plan de transformation
de l'économie française c'est aux
éditions odile jacob
et c'est un guide pratique qui propose
des solutions claires pour réussir
l'exploit de faire baisser les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de 5 % par an
soit 80% à l'horizon 2050 sans impacter
l'économie et en permettant à tout le
monde de trouver un emploi j'ai bien
résumé très bien sauf le sans impacter
l'économie parce que ça va énormément
impacter l'économie en fait le but c'est
bien de la transformer c'est ce qu'on a
essayé d'expliquer dans transformer
l'économie ce que je veux dire c'est par
les suivants quoi
transformer aimé créer des emplois alors
on veut on va transformer beaucoup
d'emplois dans cette histoire
on veut surtout que à l'arrivée tout le
monde en est un tout le monde en n'étant
pas nécessairement celui qu'on aura au
départ alors un cas concret ce qu'on
vient de voir dans la creuse avec paul
et abla une grande place est consacrée à
la mobilité dans votre livre le vélo et
les transports communs c'est bien mais
dans plein de régions c'est possible
alors souvent en france on adore le tout
ou rien c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où on a une bonne idée on pense
qu'elle doit s'appliquer à absolument
tout le monde nous ce qu'on propose là
dedans c'est de faire les choses de
manière graduelle c'est à dire à partir
du moment où progressivement on doit
avoir moins de voitures faut évidemment
commencer par là où c'est plus facile
alors là on sait ville et en particulier
celle où nous sommes en ce moment
passé par exemple de la voiture à autre
chose que la voiture dans
l'agglomération parisienne c'est plus
facile que effectivement peut-être eu là
qu'on vient de voir voilà absolument qui
doit aller voir des potes à 20 bornes
absolument il par ailleurs on ne dit pas
que la même solution doit s'appliquer à
tout le monde il faut qu'il ya un
éventail de solutions par contre ce
qu'on dit c'est que pour ça fonctionne
il faut un peu planifié fois on peut
s'organiser on va dire si on a envie
nous totalement de changer de vie à
l'échelle individuelle en général on
fait pas les choses à la dernière minute
et absolument n'importe comment on a un
plan puis on essaye de le suivre donc ce
qu'on a proposé là c'est un peu coupé
quand vous dites nous comment
sexy parce que vous n'êtes pas alors
c'est laisser l'équipe en fait vous
savez les éditeurs sont des coquins donc
il met toujours le non plus connu sur
les couvertures et en fait derrière il
se trouve que c'est moins les autres ce
soit encore moins que moi mais derrière
ce livre il ya des dizaines de gens qui
ont piloté le travail et il ya des
centaines de contributeurs des milliers
de lecteurs toutes proportions gardées
c'est un peu comme le quand j'ai créé un
rapport c'est un peu parlé même ordre de
grandeur et donc on sait l'équipe du
chiffre project et on va dire les gens
qui gravitent autour et qui de temps en
temps donner un coup de main d'accord ok
je vous ai coupé excusez moi les
histoires mais c'était votre petit
hoquet des énergies fossiles sont une
drogue dure et on est tous accros
pourquoi on est accro aux énergies
fossiles ce que c'est vachement bon en
fait la civilisation industrielle celle
qui nous a donnée justement des voitures
des smartphones de la viande pas cher et
les vacances au ski elles sont arrivées
avec les énergies fossiles quand on
regarde l'histoire des hommes depuis
quelques milliers d'années on est en
transition énergétique permanente le feu
ça date d'il ya cinq cent mille ans et
les énergies renouvelables c'est les
énergies les plus anciennes qu'on
utilise marine à voile a précédé la
marine à charbon et au diesel les
moulins à vent et à eau il y en avait
partout dans l'empiré romain est en fait
ce qui a permis l'émergence de la
magnifique cravate que vous portez et
bien c'est les combustibles fossiles
ouais là dedans il ya du pétrole
malheureusement tout est possible ici
tout ça absolument tout et ça c'est faux
cils les caméras les projecteurs les
cravates tout partout une catastrophe
les produits de maquillage qu'on m'a mis
sur le visage enfin tout ça il ya des
dérivés du pétrole là dedans donc en
fait ce qui a fait l'avènement de la
civilisation dans laquelle on vit
aujourd'hui c'est les combustibles
fossiles c'est pour ça que c'est si
difficile de s'en passer en fait la
transition énergétique c'est pas un truc
qu'on peut faire à côté des choses fut
close et le cordon oui on peut pas faire
à côte hier à côté des choses sérieuses
qui sont les retraites la géopolitique
je sais pas quoi en fait tout est lié à
ça donc tant qu'on n'arrive pas à couper
le cordon c'est très dur de couper le
cordon parce que ça veut dire en fait
changé énormément de choses 80% de la
population en ville c'est des
combustibles fossiles tous les pays qui
se mettent à consommer plein d'énergie
urbanisme leur population fait que la
nourriture va y cacher ses des
combustibles fossiles le fait qu'on se
déplace facilement vous savez c'est en
1952 que la distance moyenne parcourue
en voiture s'est mis à dépasser la
distance moyenne parcourue à pied
1952 enfin pour moi c'est pas si vieux
mais un peu après mais en face et mes
parents quoi donc à l'époque où mes
parents sont nés on faisait plus de
distance dans la journée à pied qu'en
voiture en moyenne dans le pays un tas
donc donc ccc se passer de ce qui a
totalement transformé le pays c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très difficile
ça demande beaucoup d'y réfléchir
beaucoup donc là c'est un premier par an
+1 ce qu'on a fait on est très loin
d'avoir fait tout le chemin alors c'est
un livre très pratique hyper bien foutu
pour chaque chapitre va par exemple la
mobilité quotidienne vous avez en
première page une infographie qui est
ici avec le secteur aujourd'hui il ya
les leviers pour décarbonés il ya la
transformation horizon 2050 la
résilience et l'emploi que ça va créer
et tout y passait il ya des chapitres
surtout sur la santé le logement la
culture l'automobile l'agriculture sur
quels sujets vous avez le plus sera mais
difficile à dire parce que en fait c'est
surtout c'est un projet entrepreneurial
cette affaire là et dans un projet
entrepreneurial là où on rame le plus
c'est souvent là où on a le plus de mal
à trouver les gens qui vont faire c'est
beaucoup plus ça qui nous a limité en
général que la difficulté de s'attaquer
au sujet parce qu'en terme de méthode on
avait toujours la même la méthode c'est
on va regarder ce qui est vraiment
limitant pour transformer le monde dans
lequel on vit et ce qui est limite ans
c'est pas l'argent ça va peut-être faire
sauter en l'air la personne que vous
avez interdit et juste avant de dire
comment je m'en sors avec le smic mais
en fait quand on regarde au niveau de la
politique publique on va dire c'est pas
ça qui est le plus limitant ce qui est
le plus limite ans
les ressources physiques
l'espace le métal l'énergie les mètres
carrés tous contents m² en litres en
kilowattheures et ses essais des
compétences
alors je peux prendre l'exemple des
transports mais je vais prendre
l'exemple du bâtiment aujourd'hui par
exemple dans le bâtiment ce qui fait que
les plans gouvernementaux de rénovation
des bâtiments n'avance pas vite c'est en
général après une de compétences faut
trouver les gens qui savent faire voilà
il faut trouver les artisans qui ont
envie de faire et c'est les jeunes qui
ont envie de faire ce métier enfin c'est
ça c'est ça le facteur limitant et nous
on a commencé par regarder ça d'abord
c'est créer de l'emploi oui oui le plus
compris c'est créer les emplois dont on
a besoin par exemple dans notre plan on
pense qu'il faudrait mettre 500 mille
personnes en plus dans l'agriculture
parfois les trouver aujourd'hui si vous
allez discuter avec des gens qui ont des
exploitations fruitières ou etc ils vont
vous dire quand on arrive à faire venir
du monde souvent c'est des gens qui
c'est l'immigration et les jeunes c'est
pas ça qui les fait rêver donc il ya
c'est un des facteurs limitants qu'on a
les compétences et nous c'est vraiment
comme ça qu'on est rentré dans le
problème on avait toujours la même
logique partout que ce soit l'industrie
lourde la santé la culture etc c'est
toujours pareil donc on n'a pas vraiment
ramé pour essayer d'avancer il ya des
secteurs dans lesquels c'est plus facile
de faire des propositions très
opérationnelles que d'autres week-end
par exemple dans par exemple dans le
logement c'est plus facile de faire des
propositions opérationnelles parce qu'il
n'y a rien qui ressemble plus à un
logement qu un autre logement dehors il
ya toujours des chambres à coucher des
cuisines des couloirs pour se déplacer
il faut arrêter de construire faut -
construire aujourd'hui on construit
chaque année deux fois plus qu'on ne
crée de ménage avez vous douté mais faut
arrêter blandford ça n'a pas de sens
sauf air - mais ça n'a pas de sens
arrêter totalement c'est un truc
monstrueusement brutale de toute façon
on pourrait le dire on peut s'époumoner
on fera les allées à nouveau ça nous
vaudra un peu de curiosité sur les
plateaux de télé ça n'a aucune portée
pratique qu'est ce qu'on appelle
l'écologie positive alors c'est une c
des propositions oui on peut dire ça
comme ça toute façon ce qui nous fait
rêver c'est jamais l'interdiction je
veux dire c'est pas l'interdiction qui
nous fait avancer donc on sait qu'elles
existent on sait qu'il faut en tenir
compte mais in fine et c'est pas ça qui
va nous faire lever le matin et qui va
faire qu'on a envie de faire ce qu'on
fait jamais donc là on a essayé de
tracer des directions et par ailleurs
quelque chose qui est très important
dans le domaine de l'écologie c'est
qu'il faut il faut changer ses habitudes
et changer ses habitudes tout seul c'est
très désagréable parce qu'en général on
sort du groupe dans lequel on était bien
puisqu'on se met à se comporter
différemment
et on n'a pas encore trouvé un autre
groupe dans lequel saint céré donc quand
on essaye d'agir de façon collective on
n'a pas ce problème là c'est on n'a pas
ce problème dans lequel on se sort d'un
groupe social dans lequel on est inséré
dans lequel on se sent bien et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut proposer des choses
qui relèvent de l'action collective donc
les donc par exemple qu'est ce que je
dois faire demain qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'un groupe entier devraient faire
pour faut changer de métier parce que
l'empreinte carbone de votre métier
vraiment catastrophique les dents
et l'empreinte carbone fait ça du tout
petit truc
non mais les chrétiens ou vertigineuse
comment on nourrit les milliards
d'humains sur la planète sans polluer on
pollue au moins on peut pas ne pas
polluer quand on est 8 milliards
d'hommes sur terre de toute façon c'est
juste impossible donc ce qu'on propose
là s'est graduellement d'enfer de moins
en moins c'est ça qui nous paraît être
intéressant alors qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire demain on va dire il ya des
choses qui sont assez simples à faire à
son niveau sans investissements par
exemple changer de régime alimentaire
manger progressivement moins dire
entendu pas ne pas manger de viande
voilà voilà mangez moi là c'est les
propositions qu'on fait sur
l'agriculture et comme par ailleurs on
n'a rien contre les éleveurs qui font un
bel et bien officiel on le voit c'est
beau mais je suis ils font un métier
plus difficile que vous et moi à ce
moment ce qu'il faut c'est par ailleurs
qu'on ait des dispositions qui font
qu'ils vont être capables de continuer à
exercer leur métier dans de bonnes
conditions ce qui veut dire en pratique
revaloriser les productions qu'ils
fournissent
donc il ya tout un équilibre économique
à trouver autour d'eux des propositions
qu'on fait mais nous on a commencé
encore une fois par traiter le problème
sous l'angle sous l'angle physique alors
ce qu'on peut faire au niveau individuel
donc l'alimentation on peut faire sur
les déplacements on peut faire sur les
achats une bonne partie de notre
empreinte carbone c'est à peu près 20%
c'est ce qu'on achète tous on achète un
les vêtements l'électronique les meubles
et tables et chaises absolument tout
donc par exemple ne pas se précipiter au
solde en fait alors évidemment vous
allez dire bah si on se précipite pas au
sol que deviennent les gens qui
fabriquent ce qu'on achète bien
évidemment c'est une préoccupation tout
à fait tout à fait légitime donc dans à
l'individu au consommateur d'arriver à
se modérer un peu à la collectivité de
se dire si on arrive à rendre désirable
pour la collectivité le fait de se
modérer un peu comment est-ce qu'on
réorganise l'emploi et la production
voilà c
les rôles doivent être répartis mais
quand on voit les gilet jaune c'est un
mouvement qui est né après
l'augmentation de la taxe sur l'essence
est ce que les français sont vraiment
prêts à accepter de tels sacrifices ils
sont tous inspirés gillet sont pas prêts
à être livrés à eux mêmes c'est à dire
qu'en fait ce qu'on a constaté qu'en
août autour de toutes les consultations
parce qu'on a fait on a demandé
énormément delhi dans le cadre de ce
travail on a été voir des milliers de
gens leur demandent en leur posant des
questions pour savoir ce qui leur
faisait peur ce qu'il est c'est et en
fait une des choses que les dons les
gens horreur vous moi tout le monde
c'est de pas avoir d'alternative donc là
on a vu dans le sujet qui était juste
avant la jeune femme qui dit moi j'ai
besoin de ma voiture pour venir au
travail il est juste un peu près va pas
se mettre à bosser de chez elle si elle
bosse dans un garage venue compliquer
télétravail dans le garage
donc il faut proposer des alternatives
aux gens et leur dire simplement je vais
vous montez de prix de l'essence et
débrouillez vous c'est pas une
alternative
l'alternative c'est dire par exemple on
va obliger les constructeurs à avoir une
fraction plus importante de petits
véhicules électriques et puis si la
jeune femme que vous avez interviewé a
pas les moyens de s'en acheter un on va
lui subventionnés et parce que on peut
trouver de l'argent pour ce genre de
choses aujourd'hui quand on regarde où
va l'argent il va pas nécessairement au
bon endroit et par ailleurs s'il n'y a
pas de prise pour recharger le véhicule
là où elle bosse est bon on peut
installer une donc il ya des dons qu'il
ya des investissements à faire et on
peut pas dire juste on va augmenter le
prix de l'essence et puis derrière
débrouillez vous et nous on veut pas en
entendre parler ça ça marche pas donc il
faut quand on a c'est l'idée du plan
toujours pareil il faut s'organiser
et avoir une alternative à proposer vous
avez tenté d'influencer tous les
présidents avec votre fils tank de
sarkozy hollande et maquereau qui est le
moins mauvais bilan et écologique
quand vous demandez de départager des
gens qu'on 3 4 et 5 sur 20 c'est
difficile
je sais pas vraiment répondre à cette
question on peut faire un rapide un
rapide panorama sarkozy avait fait un
truc intéressant avec le grenelle de
l'environnement il a complètement raté
sa chance en 2009 quand il a commencé à
dire l'environnement ça suffit il a
juste pas une sujet ce qui est dommage
hollande essentiellement il était sur un
sujet environnemental très j'ai une
alliance avec les verts dont je vais
m'occuper de dire du mal du nucléaire
puis je m'arrête à peu près là et macro
ont ils appris l'héritage hollande en
ayant ces il fait du maquereau en quoi
un coup oui un coup non à coup à gauche
un coup à droite il n'y a rien de
visible vraiment quoi est dû et du co et
du coup vous voulez chanter la volonté
non mais c'est alors c'est pas avant
tout aux politiques qu'on s'adresse avec
cet ouvrage c'est avant tout à leurs
électeurs en fait cet ouvrage il est
avant tout destiné non seulement aux
gens qui votent mais aux gens qui
représentent des gens qui votent
par exemple et les partenaires sociaux
depuis le début de ce travail on a noué
des contacts avec toutes les
organisations syndicales et c'est des
gens avec qui on va on aime bien aller
discuter parce que c'est évidemment les
premiers concernés quand il doit y avoir
des grandes mutations sur l'emploi on va
discuter avec des dirigeants
d'entreprise on va diriger avec des gens
du monde on va discuter pardon avec des
gens du monde académique parce qu'en
fait c'est eux qui derrière notamment
quand ils vous font face vont faire un
peu caisse de résonance et vont
influencer ce que éventuellement les
politiques pourront décider vous en avez
fréquenté quelques uns voulaient
brocardé suffisamment souvent vous savez
que les juste titre vous savez que les
politiques sont essentiellement des
exécuteurs testamentaires et réagissent
à l'opinion donc en fait il faut
s'adresser à l'opinion donc voilà c'est
ce que vous faites avec et que ses
couvertures qui tous on se retrousse les
manches merci jean marc jancovici le
plan de transformation de l'économie
française c'est aux éditions odile jacob
merci d'être venu discuter avec nous à
bientôt merci a bientot s'éteint